[Music]
have you guys seen the hashtag on
Twitter China Australia No
hashtag we back jack nope
no oh I know what it is what does me
back Jack Dorsey I just bought a bunch
of shares and he wants to keep Jack
Dorsey up pretty much why I thought it
was all the people that are like let's
keep pancakes strong what is he the
owner he's the CEO he's party at
boundaries he's the founder he's a
co-founder of a flat for no week not
like what is it oh my gosh I'm blinking
his other thing Python because I thought
he came out like last year or something
when dear pressuring him to like censor
Twitter and he's like [ __ ] y'all right
yes
but recently now Elliott management
which is a we're on the same page you
watch the episode of Star Wars 2 anyway
so Elliott management is a hedge fund
and he recently got some more stock in
Twitter and so they're trying to push
out Jack Dorsey because they believe
that the having a new CEO will make
things better in Twitter but what do you
mean better know they their talk their
whole thing is about censorship right so
they're trying to gain control so they
can censor Twitter no no they're so
they're they're mad it's a Republican
group right ahead Ron they don't mention
that in this vehicle it's so this the
CEO of that hedge fund is a Republican
donor guy and he is pissed because
Twitter a lot of conservatives feel like
Twitter censors conserving image Paul
singer yes perfect so he's a big-time
Republicans are big big big big big so
he can come out so that they won't
censor the conservatives that's what
he's his art
and then Twitter says we're doing a lot
about censorship and everybody thinks
that they're getting sensors on Twitter
but we're really not censoring anyone or
we're doing our best
I thought they were hating on the cam
girls well according to this article
because you could be right but I guess
specifically I am right what is the
article this angle here they're talking
about how they want to replace Jack in
order to have better company financial
performance and that's Twitter's
enabling of disinformation hoaxes and
toxicity had said that like without Jack
being CEO they can like better manage
that censor it that's another word for
censor look it's a convenient way of
putting it down by then it's a
convenient way of putting it by them but
ultimately that's what they want to do
exactly yeah yeah cuz if you say I want
to change the toxicity and the
misinformation yeah censorship what else
would there be yeah for sure
world all the way down the only thing
that I wasn't jumping on with double
Republican Party I don't have that
information that's it
anyway so this is Jack not Peter
Dinklage my brain and it looked like he
didn't look that homeless when he first
started I think it's just this photo if
there's in other pictures he doesn't
look looks greasy but yeah rich yeah it
looks like what's the source of this one
hmm what's the source of that makes me
yes no but they would be like no I would
think but I'm not surprised you're not
getting the full story in the article is
what I'm saying because that's why the
Lannister always pays then there's a
whole bunch of Twitter employees coming
out with this hashtag saying that they
support Jack so for this this one for
example says I've worked many major
corporations never did a CEO take three
minutes to talk with me one on one Jack
did parenthesis more than three minutes
might I add and he didn't treat me like
someone below him people speak highly of
him in rooms he's not in he's not
pretentious or egocentric so yeah
hashtag we back Jack is this article
just like let's pump up Jack Dorsey yeah
seems like it
hey by the way I got nothing personal
against Jack Dorsey
but this just sounds like it's got an
angle to it as all but Twitter is the
only like platform that still allows
porn
I love tumblr doesn't do it right like
something is done with porn right I mean
what other platform are you gonna see a
puppy [ __ ] chase its tail and in the
next one it's a cam girl with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out yeah
Twitter know I only come across the
dirty [ __ ] is when it pops in my feet
because this is like Timothy DeLaGhetto
like I don't you know I don't like the
porn I here's the thing I have I'm cool
with a lot of porn star girls so it's
like maybe the suggest the algorithm is
putting that [ __ ] on your page its
algorithm for me cuz I don't follow them
it just pops up on my feet yeah look at
your because as friends of Timothy
DeLaGhetto has liked this did you guys
watch the Joe Rogan episode where Joe
Rogan had Tim Poole on who's like uh
he's a good I don't even know he's a
commentator journalist guy and he came
on and he basically took a [ __ ] all over
Jack Dorsey and this girl in their
censorship Department or something like
like he basically had them try to
explain why they censor things and why a
lot of it seems to be conservative
things and oh yeah they didn't briefly
mention that help people were pissed
about how Trump can go off and but then
Twitter censors other people yeah try me
Trump can say whatever the [ __ ] you want
right but then but then if you're if
you're like a conservative underling
Twitter can censor you ban you all the
[ __ ] and nothing happens nothing nobody
cares about services like that because I
know that there were many had a Facebook
case where a couple of conservative
people got cancelled
and it was like that Milo you know did
he say something bad or he's he's been
cancelled
well I don't know too much Milo's not
even like he's not even I don't know I
think is he like more of a shock
politically it's not real conservative
okay yes they have that my understanding
is he's just a full-blown troll and who
even knows what his political views are
but I'm sure he's very very very ultra
ultra right yeah
yeah yeah but no but as far as
censorship goes like I'm very very very
anti censorship and so [ __ ] like this
it's it's interesting right because
because so it was it was at that point
where censoring conservative like
influencers or whatever all that stuff
yeah yeah but then it there's two sides
of the coin right like I am against
censoring political speech of any kind
but then it's it's fascinating to hear
that they want to dump Jack Dorsey right
who is a liberal and so it's like hey
because he is like some some people
think that because he's a leftist that
it makes him he's he's very biased and
he only wants just winner to be like
well leftist extravaganza place but then
Twitter doesn't censor Trump at the same
time so I think that there's a fair
argument to be made on both sides it's
just about the smaller ball people who
seem to get [ __ ] with the blue I've
never seen sweater like censoring
anybody yeah can I get both to actually
so when someone one of my friends and I
retweet like a like someone that has
leftist talking points or or the right
and then I see that so I don't I didn't
I guess I didn't realize that they did
censor conservatives well they it's
saying that they just do that like in
general is not fair to Twitter right
like it's just that voice is from the
conservative right have been have been
banned or like had been suspended or any
of that [ __ ] and so people are going
how come this only seems to happen to
one side of the aisle if your algorithm
is so fair and if you're like rights and
practices is so fair how come it's
always happen in the same guru so
they're not banning like extreme
leftists a lot of leftist will can use
can say violent things and this is what
Tim the pool is pointing out on Joe
Rogan show they can say let things they
can even do or say they'll do violent
things and Twitter doesn't seem to to
react as quickly as they will for
someone on the right who says something
crazy so what about that trend where the
girls were running up and trying to hit
the phone with their [ __ ]
I think that that was allowed okay he
did sense of that and that's why I want
to keep Jack in there because if you can
hit the phone with your [ __ ] you should
definitely not be censored funny it's so
[ __ ] funny
so you set up the phone like this yeah
girl's butt ass naked right like it's on
the better or whatever and then they
just like here and then maybe they have
a shirt on or just make it underneath
and they run and then they [ __ ] dive
and in there they try to land the [ __ ]
so you see a [ __ ] like flying it it's
called like the running [ __ ] challenge
with a flying [ __ ] challenge or some
[ __ ] it's so funny
we know that the [ __ ] landed because
you literally I mean you just hear the
[ __ ] just goes like just layer onto the
camera so if the screen goes completely
dark Tennant like yeah yeah it's good
stuff pretty fun it's really funny it's
really it's like a [ __ ] bomber just
coming to you it's yeah it's pretty
gross there's no dick challenges yes you
with the double standard bro it's not is
the female body disgusting is that what
you're saying actually is a consolation
I've seen one guy yeah it was pretty
[ __ ] hilarious well cuz it was all
girls and then one guy runs up and I'm
like no I didn't dick lamm do you guys
remember when that no tell the running
butthole challenge yeah yeah something
like that yeah yeah do you guys remember
when that asian chick was called to be
fired because she said some anti white
[ __ ] or some issues like oh [ __ ] white
people or whatever and she was supposed
to be a writer for like the New York
Times and then everybody came out up on
the right side because she's a leftist
and they said that she should be fired
right they on the right were asking for
her to be censored and fired Twitter did
not do that I agree she should not be
censored or fired for saying what she
thinks even if it's [ __ ] white people or
whatever like I think that people should
just be judged on the merits of what
they do and not censored by these big
media platforms
who I think are almost like town halls
for speech yeah so I think that a lot of
this stuff including murder should be
government regulated right I don't think
it should be as private as it is right
now where someone could be in charge who
is biased right yeah someone could be in
charge who feels one way or the other
the government wouldn't do it though
that's the debate had actually to happen
so they wouldn't do that where they
could just be like oh this is gonna go
into our bias they can well they could
right but you have an actual but give
the people that they take basically
right they're not hiding behind the fact
that we're a company and we could do
whatever you want right because if they
were a platform now like a town-hall
meeting then there will be this will be
a Supreme Court case and they'll have to
rule on it like right now people are
saying accurately twitter can [ __ ]
ban whoever they want because that's how
it is right now and I agree with that
like to an extent like like as far as
you being like your JK right and if you
don't want to work with somebody you can
get rid of them because they set a
certain thing that's easy right
but I think that when something becomes
a public forum like if JK was the public
forum bringing everybody got to say what
they think and now all of a sudden it's
so big that literally when you talk
everyone's seeing you in the public
forum I don't think it should be up to
some company who has their own YouTube
says we don't like what JK says so let's
just well what is ban or what if
coca-cola signs a brand deal with
Twitter it may say Pepsi speech is
banned Mountain Dew speeches ban I'm not
kidding like stuff like that it as silly
as it sounds if you're a biased person
who is monetarily incentivized to be a
certain way you could really [ __ ] over a
lot of people and so that's what's
[ __ ] up about it both right and left
running butthole challenge that's what I
got it we got to do it and I think that
we should do the dick challenge as well
the JK running but hole kappa the middle
guy
[Music]